[Musique]
mais aucune simple
lettre n'empêchera jacques watso de
s'exprimer il s'est donné
pour mission personnelle de dénoncer les personnes
qu'il considère comme prétendant faussement être
indigènes
il appelle cela l'usurpation d'identité
[Musique]
voici l'homme qui  qu'est-ce qui
menace de porter devant les tribunaux silva
il est un expert en vêtements autochtones
bien connu dans les médias le monde des musées
et la communauté culturelle l'
un des trop nombreux il dit que de
plus en plus de gens au
canada s'identifient comme métis
et revendiquent leurs droits  mais qui est
et qui n'est pas métisest
une question à laquelle il y a beaucoup de
[Musique]
réponses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et conteur reconnu ici il est
à un festival en Allemagne il fait aussi des
présentations dans les écoles
ses histoires ont été  publié par une
maison d'édition autochtone
en 2019 à la foire annuelle du livre de montréal,
il faisait partie d'un panel avec des auteurs autochtones
tels que josephine beckham la grande nouvelle
poétesse et cinéaste
[Music]
a travaillé avec  h la nation abénakise
depuis de nombreuses années, il a même appris la
langue abunaki
au musée abénaki d'odinak il a apporté
une contribution majeure à l'exposition
indiens au-delà de hollywood mais son
ascendance indigène
n'est pas vraiment claire pendant des années son rival
s'est présenté comme ayant une origine abénakise
mais  maintenant il a cessé de le faire, il dit
qu'il a des ancêtres indigènes mais il ne
peut toujours pas dire qui ils étaient
[Musique]
approprié a
refusé de nous donner une interview devant la
caméra lorsqu'il a été joint par téléphone,
il a dit qu'il n'avait pas menti parce que sa
grand-mère avait toujours  lui a dit qu'il
avait des origines autochtones,
il a dit qu'il se sentait autochtone
depuis qu'il était un garçon et se considérait comme
un ambassadeur culturel pour les premières
nations
[Musique]
mais d'autres membres des premières nations
ont pris la défense d'irival
dans un communiqué de presse  ils ont déclaré que même
s'il n'a pas le statut d'indigène,
il a un esprit et une âme indigènes,
ils ont même appelé à faire de l'ivar d'argent
un ho  noraire membre
de la nation abénaquise
[Musique]
pays dorares miguanz est une artiste
enseignante
et experte des coutumes indigènes
sa mission est de rapprocher les différentes
cultures
dans cette interview de 2015 elle parle de
ses origines
avec l'animatrice d'une web télé
[  Musique]
elle est l'auteur d'un livre sur l'
enseignement de la spiritualité amérindienne
elle a reçu des financements pour ses
activités professionnelles d'agences
et d'institutions
non seulement au québec et au manitoba mais aussi
en france
um
[Musique]
un expert en généalogie n'a pu trouver
aucun anishinaabi ou  algonquia
est le nom de famille d'un homme autochtone
qui était son partenaire il y a plusieurs
années,
ils ont eu un enfant mais ne se sont jamais mariés ma
mère
madame country effective
donne des cours sur les
traditions, coutumes et croyances autochtones à l'
université de marial
depuis 2008 étant autochtone  ou la métisse n'est
pas une exigence pour le poste mais l'
université va quand même se pencher sur
son
filtre de cas par exemple  des
comités efficaces seuls étrangers
n'ont jamais répondu à une demande d'
entrevue dans un courriel
son fils nous a dit que sa mère n'avait
rien fait de mal il a dit qu'elle
voulait simplement honorer son père
en lui transmettant sa culture algonquine
[Musique]
dit  elle porte la médecine de l'
esprit brillant inspirée
des pratiques ancestrales indigènes
univers express france
brésil et africains son
vrai nom est dian trobli dit
qu'elle descend d'un chef éroque
et que son grand-père est indigène
[Musique]
mais notre généalogiste n'a pu trouver aucun
indigène  les ancêtres
de sa famille ont
refusé de nous étranger une interview à la
caméra au téléphone
elle nous a dit que les archives publiques étaient
fausses elle a dit que tout ce qu'elle voulait
faire était d'aider les personnes dans le besoin
[Musique]
certaines autres personnalités publiques ont
récemment fait la une des journaux
dans le  cercle de la vie les indigènes
voient la vie de manière circulaire
la directrice d'une galerie d'
art indigène s'est identifiée comme mikma
en algonquia miti mais le
journal québécois la presse a
révélé que son ancêtre autochtone le plus proche
est né en 1680.
en réponse elle a intenté une poursuite contre
lapras son avocat nous a dit que l'
information diffusée par les médias
est fausse et diffamatoire
michelle latimer est une bien connue
réalisatrice
canadienne une enquête de la cbc a soulevé des questions
sur ses allégations
de liens familiaux avec la
première nation
kitigan zibi près de maniwaki québec mme latimer
s'est excusée d'avoir dit qu'elle venait
de cette communauté sans avoir fait
toutes les vérifications nécessaires au
préalable, mais elle a toujours prétendu être  métis
l'onf a
par la suite retiré son documentaire
inconvenient indian
de son catalogue a
été considérée comme la première
personne autochtone à occuper un poste électif de la
ville de montréal
elle a été chargée de la réconciliation
avec les premières nations
jusqu'à ce qu'un fait divers de raju canada soulève des
questions sur son identité autochtone
arrière
-plan et l'a forcée à se retirer de ce
portefeuille en
quelque sorte
[Musique]
un grand passionné de généalogie sur son site Web, il
appelle des personnalités publiques
qui, selon lui, usurpent les identités indigènes
sa méthode publiant les arbres généalogiques des gens à
chaque fois qu'il le fait, il y a donc de fortes
réactions sur les expériences des médias sociaux
un an plus tard, mary joseph a accepté d'en
discuter  événements avec nous
comme si souvent avec des personnes qui s'identifient comme
métisses, elle dit que son sentiment d'
appartenance à la nation McMahon lui
est d'abord venu des traditions orales familiales
[musique]
comme le certificat de baptême de son arrière-grand-mère,
mais notre généalogiste nous assure que ce
certificat
ne  ne prouve pas que son
arrière-grand-mère était autochtone d'
ailleurs dans les différents
recensements gouvernementaux
son arrière-grand-mère ne
s'est jamais identifiée comme autochtone
cela n'étonne pas mary joseph qui
dit que pendant longtemps de
nombreux autochtones à
travers le canada le nombre de personnes
s'identifiant comme métisse
a  ont explosé selon le
recensement de 2016 ils étaient 580
000 soit une augmentation de 334 p  ercent
en 25 ans au québec 69 000 personnes se
disent maintenant métis
une augmentation de 150 en 10 ans
même le premier ministre du québec dit qu'il a
un de ces ancêtres
[Musique]
le premier ministre ne dit pas que ça fait de lui un
métis mais certains membres du premier  nations
à qui nous avons parlé
disaient qu'ils trouvaient sa déclaration
offensante partout où
ils se tournaient ils croisaient de plus en plus de québécois
avec ce nouveau sentiment de légitimité
à leur égard ce coming out massif d'indigènes
même si c'est bien intentionné
est devenu épuisant et
docteur
[Musique]
m
[  Musique]
[Musique]
dominic est le chef d'une association
de métis
dans la région de bose au québec la
nation sartigan
elle a d'abord fondé toute la communauté
en 2007
mais ensuite ce groupe s'est séparé aujourd'hui
150 de ses membres ont suivi le chef
cote
pour former le satsigan  nation elle dit
que c'est sa grand-mère qui lui a révélé
son origine autochtone
une communauté que l'histoire a oublié et un
village qui a disparu où la
municipalité québécoise de ce  vichdale de
bose
se tient maintenant
euh au québec il y a 11 peuples
autochtones
qui sont reconnus par le
gouvernement fédéral chaque membre de ces groupes
a au moins un ancêtre autochtone
moins de trois générations en arrière les
organisations métisses comme dominic cortese
ne sont pas reconnues
et n'ont pas de droits autochtones  mais
beaucoup se battent encore
pour leur obtenir des
collaborations
[Musique]
en décembre 2019 jacques wetzo a publié
ce communiqué de presse
au nom de sa nation il déclare que
chef cote et son groupe
sont des voleurs d'identité
[Musique]
dit
difficile de savoir en effet il y a des
associations métisses comme  la nation satsigan
dans pratiquement toutes les régions du québec est-
il possible qu'il y ait en fait
autant de communautés métisses
que l'histoire a oubliées sur ce point
les opinions des chercheurs divergent
[Musique]
est professeur à l'université carleton il
étudie les groupes métis qui essaient de
se faire
reconnaître il  estime que ces groupes
doivent être examinés
au cas par cas avec  deux autres
chercheurs il a publié un livre
intitulé qui traite des origines
du peuple métis dans la région d'ottawa
a une vision différente du mouvement métis
en 2019 il a publié un livre
intitulé distorted descend whiteclaims to
native identity
qui appelle ces autoproclamés
indigènes  gens race
shifters professeur à l'université st mary's à
halifax il n'hésite pas à remettre en question
l'authenticité
de ces groupes de métis dans l'est du canada d'
accord parce
qu'étranger pour obtenir des droits autochtones en tant que
métis
ayant un ancêtre autochtone quelque part
dans votre famille et étant membre de  une
association métisse
ne suffit pas vous devez prouver que
vous appartenez à une communauté métisse
historique  s'occuper soigneusement
[Musique]
une communauté qui veut obtenir les
droits des métis doit montrer qu'elle a un sha
culture rouge et coutumes et traditions
qui constituent une identité métisse
distincte de celles
des premières nations et des européens et prouvent
que cette tradition
a duré dans le temps c'est le test pauli
énoncé dans une décision de la cour suprême les
enfants mes petits-enfants peuvent
être comme leurs ancêtres chassent quand  ils
veulent steve powley et la
communauté métisse de la société mari a passé
ce test avec succès en 2003 et a
ainsi obtenu
les droits autochtones cette
décision de la cour suprême a déclenché le mouvement métis à
travers le canada
sénateur
près de 110 associations au québec et
ailleurs au canada
sont allées devant les tribunaux confiantes qu'elles le
feraient  obtenir la reconnaissance
et les droits généralement les droits de chasse et de pêche
[Musique]
alors que dominikoty était le chef de toute la
communauté métisse
certains de ses membres voulaient pouvoir
produire du sirop d'érable sans avoir à
suivre les
[Musique]
une danseuse traditionnelle a  conseil un groupe
d'anciens
tous destinés à aider les gens à trouver leurs
racines et ce  lébrent leur culture
mais ils donnent l'impression que la
nation satsigan est l'une des premières nations
[Musique]
respecte
que la grand-mère de dominique cote était
indigène comme elle le prétend
[Musique]
pense que même les gens qui n'ont pas d'
ancêtres indigènes ont le  droit de
s'identifier comme métis
il pense qu'il faut aller au-delà de la
généalogie et considérer leur mode de
vie
selon les archives
publiques l'ancêtre indigène le plus proche de
sebastimalet était seiferous tepaque né au 17ème
siècle
mais malet dit que cette information est
fausse et qu'il accorde plus d'importance
à ce que son père lui a dit
[Musique] la
plupart des associations de métis délivrent une
carte de membre
dominic cote en avait une lorsqu'elle était chef
de toute la communauté
ces cartes ressemblent souvent à celles que
le gouvernement fédéral délivre
aux indiens inscrits certaines personnes font
un usage frauduleux de leur métis
cartes de membre
pour être exonérés de taxes sur leurs
achats comme une voiture neuve par exemple
la fraude
nation no lon  ger délivre des cartes à ses
membres précisément parce que la chef cote
dit qu'elle avait trouvé des cas de
fraude
disponibles
[Musique]
à ce jour, seule la communauté métisse de la
société ontario
a réussi le test de pauli tous les 110
autres groupes métis ont échoué dans  leurs
tentatives d'obtenir une reconnaissance légale
au québec l'affaire judiciaire qui a retenu le
plus l'attention a été entendue
insignilexia gisele corno avait construit un
camp de chasse sur un terrain public
et avait refusé de le démolir au
motif qu'il était
métis trois organisations métisses représentant
près de 12 000 personnes
s'est joint à lui en tant que demandeurs pour revendiquer ses
droits autochtones
après plus de 11 ans de litige
la cour supérieure du québec a rejeté
leurs revendications
dans sa décision le juge rajiv a écrit que
la preuve montrait que gizenko sait que l'
auto-identification comme métis était un
phénomène assez récent
dicté par l'opportunisme
la personne est
[Musique]
pour devenir membre d'une
association métisse et avoir une carte
il faut remplir un formulaire
fournir la preuve que vous avez un
ancêtre autochtone parfois une simple
déclaration sur l'honneur
suffira et ensuite payer une cotisation
qui varie de 40 à 260
selon l'association vous devez
payer une cotisation annuelle nous avons
voulu voir si c'était facile ou difficile  pour obtenir
une carte d'une association
nous avons demandé à une collègue d'essayer d'en obtenir une
dans la mesure où elle sait qu'elle n'a pas d'
ascendance autochtone
néanmoins elle a rempli le formulaire pour
devenir membre de la plus grande
organisation représentant les métis
au québec l'alliance autochtone du québec
[Musique]
fondée dans les années 1970 l'alliance autochtone
du québec a une longue histoire de conflits internes
au milieu des années 2000 elle était sur le point de
se disloquer
le nouveau chef guillaume cal menait
une guerre sans merci
contre certains membres influents de l'
organisation il y avait  nombre de
réunions bruyantes
et de procès en colère
[Musique]
à la suite de guillaume cal est parti
et a fondé sa propre association
en 2018 c'est devenu le targ  et d'un
chef d'enquête de cbc, cal recrutait des membres en
faisant analyser leur ADN
dans un laboratoire, le cbc a
pu montrer que les conclusions du laboratoire
étaient plus que douteuses dans l'adn
des membres du personnel de cbc
de russie et d'inde et même dans un
échantillon de salive de chien
il a trouvé des gènes indigènes 12 pour cent
abénaquis
et 8 pour cent mohawk guillaume cal a déposé
une poursuite en diffamation contre la radio-canada pour
ce rapport
l'alliance autochtone du québec est la
seule association représentant les métis au
québec
qui reçoit un financement fédéral en 2020 elle a
reçu plus d'un million de dollars
euh
[  Musique]
a également été chef de l'alliance autochtone
de 2011 à 2016.
il a ensuite été élu chef national
du congrès des peuples autochtones
du canada seuls les métis des
provinces et territoires de l'ouest et suse mari
sont reconnus par le gouvernement fédéral
comme un peuple autochtone  le congrès des
peuples autochtones
est une organisation politique basée à
ottawa qui lutte pour la reconnaissance
des autres  euh les métis à travers le
pays le congrès dit qu'il
représente aussi tous les autochtones vivant
hors réserve
le gouvernement fédéral donne au
congrès près de cinq millions de dollars par
année a
été député fédéral
et fonctionnaire pendant de nombreuses années
c'est lui qui a convaincu pierre  -el
trudeau de reconnaître les droits des
peuples autochtones
dans la charte des droits et libertés à
son avis les
organismes représentant les métis
qui ne sont pas reconnus officiellement par
ottawa
ne devraient pas recevoir de financement gouvernemental
par courriel le ministère des
affaires autochtones nous a dit qu'ils travaillent avec
le  congrès des peuples autochtones
pour faire avancer la cause de la réconciliation
euh
selon nos recherches,
l'ascendance autochtone de kraber bertrand
remonte aux années 1600,
le volcan leader
soutient qu'il a
des ancêtres autochtones contemporains dans sa famille mais
il ne peut pas dire qui ils sont,
il dit qu'il  pris au piège avec son père
depuis l'enfance cet indigenou  du sang
coule dans ses veines
et qu'il est fier d'être métis
mais revenons à notre collègue elle
n'a toujours pas reçu sa carte de l'
alliance autochtone du québec
mais elle a été surprise d'apprendre
qu'elle répond aux critères pour l'obtenir
en remplissant son arbre généalogique elle
découvrit qu'elle avait un ancêtre indigène
une femme dont le nom est inconnu et qui
épousa johnny collette un proche
collaborateur de samuel de champlain en 1629
le même ancêtre que dominic
louis jose pierre cal pelado et même le
premier ministre justin trudeau
[Musique]
dit famille satan
étrangère
[Musique]
algonquin et c'est kamek elle vient de
prendre sa retraite après 25 ans de travail
auprès des détenus autochtones elle veut
dénoncer ce qu'elle a vu
au service correctionnel du canada
[Musique]
la direction des initiatives autochtones
était  mis sur pied pour répondre aux besoins des
détenus des premières nations
qui sont surreprésentés dans le système pénal
pour que cette direction puisse mener à bien sa
mission  le service correctionnel du
canada a
besoin de personnel autochtone pour certains postes clés
être autochtone est même obligatoire
pour moi cindy wilde s'est alors rendu compte que
certains de ses collègues avaient revendiqué
des origines autochtones
pour obtenir les emplois en question en
premier
[Musique]
première nation une des onze
nations autochtones reconnues  au québec,
elle aussi a travaillé pour la direction des initiatives autochtones
appelée cindy et dominic ont déposé des plaintes
sur la situation
auprès de la commission de la fonction publique mais
en vain
pour se qualifier pour un emploi ouvert uniquement
aux autochtones,
vous devez remplir une auto-déclaration
formulaire où vous vous identifiez
comme autochtone le
service correctionnel du canada
ne vérifie pas plus loin
ce même formulaire d'auto-déclaration est utilisé
dans tous les ministères fédéraux
le gouvernement du québec utilise un formulaire similaire
il n'y a pas que les employés correctionnels qui
ont de bonnes raisons de se déclarer
autochtone
les détenus font aussi certains des avantages
incluent plus de fréquence  ent visitent
des services adaptés à la culture et la
possibilité
d'obtenir une libération conditionnelle plus tôt ce qui
crée
des situations étranges
est les aînés jouent un rôle important dans
la culture autochtone
dans le système correctionnel ils sont
embauchés pour aider à réhabiliter les détenus
si important
cliquez
[Musique]
une situation qui est difficile à croire  un
aîné qui n'est pas vraiment autochtone
et un agent de liaison
autodéclaré autochtone sur un formulaire
travaillant en relation d'aide avec un
détenu qui n'est pas plus autochtone qu'eux
le service correctionnel du canada a
refusé notre demande d'entrevue
par courriel  le service nous a dit que tous les
employés ont le droit de s'autodéclarer
et qu'il n'a pas le pouvoir de
déterminer si quelqu'un est autochtone
ou non
il a même dit que le
service correctionnel du canada est fier d'être le
plus grand
employeur d'autochtones au  la
fonction publique fédérale
a participé à de nombreuses
négociations fédérales avec les peuples autochtones
et à  son opinion ottawa doit établir
une définition claire de métis
[musique]
les deux étrangers pour les affaires
autochtones et les services autochtones
carolyn bennett et mark miller ont refusé
de nous accorder une entrevue
par courriel le ministère des affaires autochtones a
dit qu'il ne peut pas définir qui
est métis  et qui n'est pas l'une des
raisons d'une
décision de la Cour suprême en 2016.
dans l'affaire daniels, la plus haute cour du canada a
conclu que les métis
relèvent de la compétence fédérale, ils sont
considérés comme des indiens au sens
de la loi constitutionnelle,
mais pour garantir les droits des autochtones, ils
doivent  satisfaire au test de pauli devant les
tribunaux
mais sur la question de l'identité métisse
le tribunal est resté silencieux
le tribunal a laissé le soin aux métis de se
définir
et au gouvernement fédéral de décider
[Musique]
donc qui est ou n'est pas métis aujourd'hui sont des
métis  survivants du colonialisme canadien
et des politiques assimilationnistes ou usurpateurs
de l'identité autochtone,
le débat est susceptible de se poursuivre pendant quelques
ti  moi ça fait rage sur les réseaux sociaux
alors que le milieu universitaire reste
divisé
un tel dialogue est impossible il
continue de voir les membres du
mouvement métis dans l'est du canada comme
[musique]
au québec et ailleurs au canada les
associations de métis se poursuivent  de s'organiser
et d'affirmer leur existence et leurs
droits si la population métisse continue
de croître à son rythme actuel d'
ici 15 ans les métis seront
plus nombreux que les peuples des premières nations au canada
tôt ou tard le
gouvernement devra faire face à ce
phénomène grandissant et essayer  pour trouver des
solutions